having the white pieces  i i feel that this is kind of nice it's  not like anish can target some uh  some grim fed you know of uh of of nils  because niels is not exactly a full-time  grim fat player yeah and i really feel  like if you play the greenfield you have  to be an incredible big specialist  otherwise it's it's very dangerous and  also we know that anish of course with  all the move orders he has some auntie  grim fed or whatever he can be cause  he's in trouble  i can definitely confirm that this is  not always fun to have to have the black  side of the green field against an issue  can definitely be a bit of a bit of a  problem  yeah so i was actually quite happy and  yeah it's it's not only when we talk  about the georgian team it's it's not  only bad  this is very important to to mention  that this is a very very experienced  team with a lot of lot of olympians  behind them  uh on second board chadlis really very  very experienced player aboard 3